in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Dave
and Brandi are here hey guys how are you
I believe hi Dave welcome welcome where
y'all from we're from st. Charles
Missouri which is right outside the st.
Louis it surely is welcome to Nashville
good to have you and you're here to do a
debt-free scream yes sir how much of you
paid off seventy five thousand eight
hundred and forty seven dollars and
seventeen cents excellent how long did
that take you twenty three months very
good and making what range of income
during have we started at 1:10 and we're
now at 1:34 cool very cool and so what
do you guys do for a living I'm a real
estate appraiser and I'm a payroll
supervisor okay now I was talking to a
lady in New York that last week that
called to interview me from one of the
big news thingies up there they're doing
a story that they probably won't use me
for because of what I told her but the
basis of the story was was that the the
the middle-class income that the middle
class's income is stagnant and I was
telling her about people like you that I
meet all the time that are standing here
to do a debt free scream and during
twenty three months your income went
from 110 to 130 four doesn't sound
stagnant to me and with both of you
working that would make you middle class
and upper middle class but middle class
and so how did your income go up since
the economy so bad and middle-class
incomes are stagnant well I got two
promotions and then Brandi being a real
estate appraiser she owns her own
company so depending on what the real
estate market is in st. Louis brainy's
income fluctuates up and down and how
many actually how actually how hard she
actually works - right okay there's
always that yeah I worked my tail off
exactly I mean the more appraisers you
do appraisals you do the more money my
yeah okay very cool and when you have a
goal and you're trying to get out of
debt you do more appraisal exactly as
long as somebody will hire you to do
that excellent so will tell me the story
what happened 23 months ago that starts
you on this fabulous journey to get out
of debt well about 26 months ago the
coffin girl here is uh came into our
lives so we had our first daughter three
months after that our
HVAC system went out so two times your
alarm your life alarm clock went off
that's new baby
no HVAC I'm gonna have to address this
absolutely and about that time my
manager at the time
his name's clay led me to you I said
there's this guy named Dave Ramsey that
you need to check out at least google
and see what's going on mm-hmm so they
did that and I remember going to his
office a few times saying this is too
simple I have my degree in finance I
have my MBA and this is just way too
simple but lo and behold that's all you
need live on less than you make and pay
it on the debt yep yeah it is too simple
you're right yeah that's it very cool so
you start lit yeah how'd you how'd you
connect up with us through like I said
my manager at the time uh-huh but I mean
you you listen the podcast or you listen
the radio show or guys listen to the
podcasts okay so then you come home to
Brandi and she says she's working you
know slaving over and appraised on you
say hey I think we can get out of debt
by living on less than we make what you
say Brandi I was ready I was tired of
every time our tax season came around we
always were saying where's are all of
our money going oh so I was ready for it
okay so you had already run the numbers
already had a healthy level of disgust
and then you were like awesome he
finally gets it right yeah okay so then
what did you guys do well we started
doing our budget how we put every bit of
money on on the table and we just
started working our budget as as you
know spending every dollar that we could
on paper yeah
very started working together we
combined our checking accounts which was
a big step for us for me I guess why was
that a big step for you for so long
we just we've been married a long time
just for so long she had her sign and I
had mine how long you been married we
just celebrated 10 years in March okay
very cool all right yeah that's a long
time and then all of a sudden you're
gonna try something two completely new
that is uncomfortable
oh yeah it's legitimately uncomfortable
you really did say I'm all-in
I mean that's what you were doing with
that oh yeah we went but bought the
books and I was pretty much a die hard
from that moment on okay
Total Money Makeover financial piece in
the fall that year when they needed the
class okay very cool
good good very cool what kind of debt
was the 76,000 we had two cars Dave
student loans the HVAC system and some
flooring we put in right before we
started and which one of those debts was
like the one you said I hate you and I'm
so glad you're gone my car because it
was last okay and you kept the cars but
you paid them off yeah so you just you
just did beans and rice for hard for two
years basically we did have a third car
and had 240,000 miles on it and we sold
it and made like two grand but yeah not
much but other than that you just just
lowered the lifestyle but nothing we
said no to everything quit eating out
did people make fun of you
well I wouldn't say we got me fun of
brainy likes we haven't asked if we were
a part of the Dave Ramsey Church shave
your head and drink the kool-aid but you
joined the cult yeah I haven't done that
yet so make it fun uh wasn't that much
as much as I remember hearing having
stories with people I've told I was
going through Dave Ramsey purlins
program and you know basically their
excuse was you just don't like to go out
like like we do you know I don't I don't
want to spend my money on or they do
they won't spend their money on going
out and buying maybe everybody in the
whole establishment a drink where we
didn't want to live that wolf guitar
fine when Charlotte's goes through
college and it's still debt-free you
know what when you walk in and you're
looking in the face of a little baby
it changes your need to impress other
people absolutely you got one job then
don't you me it changes everything it
really does I think it I think it's
called growing up but I mean you just do
you just go you know I don't care what
you think all I cares what she thinks
it's little baby right here's my job and
that changes everything man that makes
you a good daddy good mommy you guys are
very neat I'm proud of you excellent
excellent job and Charlotte is queues a
button with those curls yeah so get her
over here to do our debt free scream all
right Dave and brandy and Charlotte and
she's 26 months old right that's right
yep two years and two months and so she
is a debt free baby I mean she's a debt
no ball babies yes the whole time she's
been alive you've been dead snowballing
$76,000 paid off in 23 months making a
hundred and ten to one hundred and
thirty-four Dave Brandi and Charlotte
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
love it love it love it Wow if that
cutie doesn't get you motivated to be a
grown up nothing will oh my gosh she's
adorable what a great couple and what a
great story
see there's always a transformational
aspect to this and that's why I want you
to hear when I'm having these folks on
doing their debt-free screams because
you can't it's this is not a math
problem you can't just go okay I'm going
to now manipulate the mathematics no you
have to deal with the person in your
mirror that couple combined their
finances for the first time in ten years
of married life that's a major
transformation they sat down and agreed
on their spending on paper on purpose
before the month begins that's a major
transformation but you won't do that
until you have a real reason to do that
you're either just sick and tired of
being sick and tired
stuff like the heat and air breaks and
you can't fix it that's like you have
one of those moments where you go that's
it I've had it I'm not living like this
anymore or you can get a more beautiful
why discussed as a reasonably good why
but a more beautiful why is little
Charlotte a kids family trees changed
that couple right there I mean they're
making a hundred thirty-four thousand
dollars a year they don't have any
payments but a house payment can you
imagine how wealthy they're going to be
how wealthy Charlotte's gonna be that's
pretty impressive you can change your
family tree you can change your life you
can change your destiny in America today
middle-class wages are stagnant the
middle class is shrinking yep
but you could choose not to participate
you can decide I'm going to work more
when we're Carter them and we're
different I'm gonna change my career
your wages may be stagnant but mine
aren't you get to decide that starting
now
ready set go
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right it's kind of
better than the dayroom the channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you